what do you think about
in terms of this co-evolution of um the
work around brain computer interfaces
and
maybe uh neural link and and elon
seeing neural link in particular
as its long-term mission as a
symbiosis with artificial intelligence
so
like giving a greater bandwidth
channel of communication between
technology ai systems and the biological
uh neural networks of our human mind
what do you think about this idea of
connecting directly
to the brain right in ai systems
i mean okay i've i've listened to
your podcast with alan i've listened to
a lot before a very intel
obviously super smart guy um i think
this is already
i mean not in the specific ways that he
is doing it
but i think we are already doing that
okay and i can give you some examples
um and there are really trivial examples
but they do make the point
and this is one of them so
before i started this research on ufos
and eops
and technology i actually was looking at
the effects
of technology and
in particular media on religion and
what i did was i was lucky to be asked
to be
a consultant for various movies and
one in particular i learned a lot from
and that was the conjuring
so that i was a history consultant
for the conjuring it happens to be my
field it's catholic studies right
and you've got these people who are real
people and they're you know exercising
demons and things like that okay so i
thought
wow this is a great example for me you
know i didn't do it for the money
it doesn't pay well but i did it to
learn right so
i work closely with the screenwriters
who i work with now all the time with i
work
with them all the time now and what i
found was this i found that
as the most interesting part of the um
creation of this movie was the editing
process
because they would use the it would go
through
editing and they would use test
audiences and a lot of the test
audiences
um would be like you know there's like
these things where they test their
flicker rates and things like that the
eye flicker rates
and so and the uh and it when it goes
really intense they go to uc irvine and
they do this thing called
cognitive consumption which is basically
um or i'm sorry cognitive consumerism
where they basically hook test audiences
up to
ekgs and they read their brains yeah and
they figure out which
scenes create the most arousal yeah
and so they cut out all the other scenes
okay
so what we're getting is we're getting
like this drug when we go to the movies
or when we do video games when we watch
we're literally physiologically
responding
to our technologies so we're already
there we're already interfacing with
them physiologically
so that's my example now the the kind of
thing that he's doing
uh musk is doing with neurolink i say
go for it that's awesome i hope he does
it you know i'm fascinated
i want it to happen um why do i want it
to happen
because i think that well first it's
inevitable that
it's going to happen um i also want to
point out that jacques valet was trying
to get this done back
in the 60s and the 70s he was writing
papers about in fact the arpanet
the pro proto-internet um was called
augmentation of the human intellect so
we've been doing this for a while okay
so um props to elon musk
but we've been thinking about this for a
good time um we've even been
visioning it okay so there was a
really interesting jesuit priest
he was french uh tell your deshardan i
don't know if you know who he is
if not he's fascinating he was a he was
actually a soldier
uh before he became a priest and so he
believed he also saw what he called a
biosphere
now this guy is talking in like the
early 20th century like the 19
17 19 you know that time period and so
basically he
he said and wrote about this thing
called the new sphere
and he basically said there will be a
point when we merge with our technology
and it's going to be somewhat like some
kind of a biosphere we have this
atmosphere and then we have the
stratosphere and it's going to be this
biosphere and we're all going to be
hooked into it
mentally so we'll be able to communicate
in a way in which we don't communicate
now
so you know that sounds so similar to
the singularity
you